[Música]
todos alguna vez hemos escuchado frases
como corres como niña pegas como niña tú
cállate mejor ve a lavar los platos
maneja pésimo seguramente es vieja o una
frase que recientemente leí que decía
todas las mujeres son independientes
hasta el momento en el que tienen que
cargar un garrafón si nos damos cuenta
todas estas frases responder a un tema
de fuerza y coordinación y es cierto las
mujeres fisiológicamente tenemos menos
fuerza respecto a un hombre sin embargo
he visto mujeres que por ejemplo quien
abre una botella de agua y se le
entregan al hombre más cercano que
tienen como si ellas no fueran capaces
de realizar esta simple acción
muchas veces la dependencia comienza por
nosotras mismas y no nos percatamos de
eso y así como tú yo también he vivido
las consecuencias del machismo en mi
vida cotidiana
y les platico yo soy deportista de alto
rendimiento y nosotras como deportistas
podemos reducir esta brecha de fuerza
entre hombres y mujeres e inclusive
podemos ser más fuertes que un hombre
promedio que no está involucrado y que
no ha estado involucrado durante toda su
vida con el deporte pero porque nosotras
entrenamos cinco horas al día y llevamos
años y años de entrenamiento dicho esto
les platico una historia que comúnmente
me pasa en el gimnasio
donde por ejemplo estoy alternando algún
aparato con un muchachón y me preguntan
como por default cuánto peso quieres que
le quite no te vayas a lesionar yo te
apoyo cuando en realidad la pregunta
debería de ser en mi caso cuánto peso le
añado porque pues en varias ocasiones
cargo más que ellos qué es lo que pasa
con esto desde que somos niños se nos
asignan roles de género de forma
consciente e inconsciente normalizada y
esto va generando estereotipos me
acuerdo en un curso de verano cuando era
niña que mis amigas
se quedaban viendo a los niños jugar
fútbol echándole porras en un rol
claramente pasivo mientras que yo era la
única niña que a la par que ellos subía
metía goles o bajaba a defender
estas historias que les cuento no
necesariamente nos dejan con una
sensación de violencia sin embargo nos
catalogan como el sexo débil el que no
está capacitado el que no es apto o el
que
no tiene una oportunidad para jugar
ejemplo una cascarita y estas
situaciones son las que llamamos
micromachismos todas estas situaciones
en nuestra cotidianeidad que vivimos y
sin darnos cuenta contienen una carga de
machismo pero no nos percatamos
siempre voy a estar agradecida con la
familia los valores las vivencias que
hasta el día de hoy compartimos yo
provengo de una familia donde la equidad
de género es lo normal y no una rareza
donde jamás se me asignaron tareas
domésticas digamos como por el simple
hecho de ser mujer y donde viví siempre
entre dos situaciones totalmente
extremas fue una parte mi papá siempre
alentaba en mi actitudes de fuerza lucha
hacer tosca esté ruda sin miedo a nada
mientras que por otra parte mi amada
siempre forjó una niña femenina delicada
sensible muchas veces ingenua y
totalmente sobreprotegida a medida que
fui creciendo me vinculé con los hombres
de diferentes formas ejemplo en
noviazgos y viví de forma sutil lo que
es el machismo enmascarado tras este
concepto que hemos forjado socialmente
como caballerosidad en donde me hacían
la vida más sencilla no tenía por qué
preocuparme todo lo tenía resuelto
y le cedía a alguien parte de mi
independencia justamente esto mi
independencia fue lo que yo fui a
rescatar a revivir a retomar a hexatlón
el reality show más exitoso de todos los
tiempos en la televisión mexicana espero
que alguien para acá lo haya visto y si
no lo vieron les va a contar que es esto
esa flor es una competencia de alto
rendimiento y en mi generación de
supervivencia éramos 20 competidores
estábamos divididos en dos equipos
el equipo azul el contendiente es el mío
y el equipo de famosos el rojo
dentro de estos participantes sabíamos
deportistas amateurs centroamericanos
panamericanos olímpicos había boxeadores
profesionales futbolistas profesionales
actrices que semanalmente vivíamos la
posibilidad de ser eliminados de esta
competencia por nuestro rendimiento
físico o también por la decisión del
público
les voy a contar un poco cómo era un
circuito para que sientan la vibra que
nosotros nos vivíamos y también la gente
detrás de la pantalla eran
aproximadamente 100 metros donde había
muchísimos obstáculos teníamos que
saltar correr nadar nos callamos nos
levantábamos muchas veces nos lesionamos
y llegamos a esa parte final que eran
tiros de precisión así que imagínense
llegar así con 180 pulsaciones y tenemos
que tener el temple la seguridad
la concentración que era muy difícil
para embocar por ejemplo 5 pelotas en un
aro y así obteníamos un punto si les
tengo que confesar porque accedí a
participar en esta competencia no fue
necesariamente por ser la ganadora de
los 2 millones de pesos que era el gran
premio o por ser famosa y salía en la
tele estaba atravesando como cualquiera
de nosotros hemos a través de alguna vez
una relación no un castigo porque no
éramos relación un noviazgo tóxico
que me está haciendo la vida día a día
muy complicado y decidí tomarme un break
y la
la impresión de todas las personas que
me rodeaban escribe a regresar de esta
competencia muy rápido o sea que me iban
a eliminar pronto y la cuestión no era
la capacidad física sino más bien mi
personalidad el contexto del que vengo
que no empataban claramente con lo que
nos iban a hacer vivir allá que era una
especie de selección natural artificial
una historia que tengo super presente
ahorita pues la toma a la ligera pero en
su momento no me dio nada de gracia es
que una chava de forma muy directa en
nuestro primer desayuno como equipo me
dijo de forma así como súper frontal y
directa algo así como mac y tú qué haces
aquí
te ves toda femenina fresa super
consentida sabes a qué te estás metiendo
by the way esta chava fue la primera
eliminada le mando saludos y también una
enseñanza de esto es que todos siempre
nos presentamos teniendo prejuicios y
estereotipos y pues la verdad no
deberían hacer además hacer así las
cosas que fue lo que en realidad pasó
resulta ser la mujer finalista de esta
competencia con cinco meses vividos en
república dominicana en las condiciones
más sufridas difíciles puedo decir
también traumáticas insalubres que se
puedan imaginar pero también en concreto
los cinco mejores meses que han marcado
un antes y un después de mi vida y que
siempre voy a estar agradecida porque se
me dio esta oportunidad
si pudiera definir en tres etapas lo que
viví la primera sería shock por conocer
lo que íbamos a estar sometidos durante
tanto tiempo
la segunda desesperación porque quería
salir de ahí no podía había firmado un
contrato estaba totalmente atrapada y la
tercera adaptación en esta etapa
me había adaptado físicamente
espiritualmente deportivamente
fisiológicamente
todo lo que se me presentaba lo resolvía
de la mejor forma nada me sorprendía
nada me daba miedo llegué a estar en un
estado zen que jamás había experimentado
en el que solo me importaban tres cosas
como que me volví muy muy animal muy
básica me importaba sobrevivir me
importaba que mi idea de dios estuviera
orgulloso de lo que hacía y la última no
fallarle a mi compañero de equipo el
resto casares en una etapa muy difícil
de la competencia en la que sólo
quedábamos dos representantes del equipo
de contendientes que constantemente nos
estamos enfrentando ante cinco grandes
oponentes entre los que había
deportistas olímpicos y panamericanos y
que literal siempre sacarán nuestra
mejor versión y qué fue lo que pasó uno
a uno los fuimos eliminando y hagamos mi
compañero y yo juntos a la final
en una historia que realmente es
imposible pero lo hicimos posible y otra
enseñanza que nos deja esto es que jamás
en la vida hay un competidor débil
la final soñada entre la audiencia entre
la misma producción
me imagino también entre los propios
participantes era entre dos hombres los
dos más rápidos de los circuitos sin
embargo pues el desenlace fue diferente
al ser una mujer y un hombre los que
tenían que competir pues no se nos dio
la oportunidad de competir físicamente
porque se creía que las condiciones iban
a ser injustas y por lo tanto la
audiencia por medio de votos decidió
quién iba a ser el ganador
esta fue la primera vez en mi vida donde
me sentí como esas niñas que les conté
el principio en este curso de verano
donde nos sientan donde no nos dejan ser
protagonistas de una historia que nos
pertenece y donde simplemente no se nos
da ese voto de confianza
independientemente fuese cual fuese el
resultado de esta competencia a mí me
hubiera gustado competir contra un
hombre por el poderoso mensaje de
equidad de género que se hubiera dado a
la audiencia que nos veía y qué tanta
urgencia y falta hacen en nuestra
sociedad
muchas veces de riéndome pero también
muy seria le digo a ese muchachito de
ahí que me hubiera gustado competir
contra él de forma física
y también le he comentado que si no se
hubiera puesto buzo en la parte final de
los tiros de precisión donde todo se
definía le hubiera ganado porque después
de cinco meses de de volverme obsesiva
con el entrenamiento de tiros
de ser la peor al definir un máster
y bueno también pueden decir subcampeona
el segundo lugar de esta competencia
pero como en realidad yo me siento es
como la campeona femenil de hexatlón y
no sólo por
las condiciones físicas demostradas allí
sino también por todos los aprendizajes
todas las
vivencias o el crecimiento personal que
obtuve
algo curioso sobre el machismo es que
bueno cuando regrese de esta experiencia
y me topé con todos los comentarios que
se habían dicho sobre mí y bueno es
sobre todos los participantes pero bueno
los comentarios eran así como de la
final fue un fraude amac y lo ayudaron a
llegar hasta la final tenía amigos en la
producción tenía compadritos en la
producción tenía relaciones
sentimentales con alguien de la
producción a otra hipótesis era su
familia había comprado la final y
obviamente después de tanta
vivida en estos cinco meses pues me dio
el ataque no pero también comprendí
cosas que nos suceden a las mujeres que
vamos ascendiendo que vamos acercándonos
al éxito donde siempre buscan mermar
estos procesos porque a los hombres
jamás se les va a poner en tela de
juicio su integridad o su valor o su
esfuerzo
obviamente me quedo con todos los
comentarios positivos con toda la gente
que me apoyó a lo largo de esta larga
aventura y que vieron mi constancia mi
evolución mis procesos mis valores mi
disciplina y el mensaje que fue muy
claro todas las personas que trabajamos
duro por lo que queremos lo podemos
obtener independientemente sea cual sea
nuestro género o el contexto social del
que vengamos
lo que necesitamos en méxico son mujeres
empoderadas por todos grandes esferas el
deporte y la educación
esta es una dualidad infalible que nos
va a permitir ser autónomas y también
ocupar el rol que queramos en nuestra
sociedad no nos conformemos nunca con
pequeñeces con estereotipos con roles de
género que ni hoy ni nunca nos han
definido como mujeres porque una mujer
puede ser bonita sensible delicada
femenina pero también puede combinar eso
con su lado de lucha perseverancia
fuerza determinación consecución de
metas
bueno
un agujero en concreto puede pegar tan
fuerte como quiera puede correr tan
rápido como se lo proponga puede crear
imaginar puede ejecutar pero que tenemos
que hacer es atrevernos a hacerlo hacer
esas protagonistas de nuestra historia
las invito a todas a que nos levantemos
de esos bancos en los que por muchos
años nos han querido sentar
ya que luchemos día a día por esa
equidad de género por esa igualdad que
urge en cada esfera de nuestra sociedad
muchas gracias